I just I just think that everybody
operates on a base level yeah like you
mentioned from where they are and
they're like if I can make this now it's
like it's like you know if
I don't know if if I if I if it was the
worlds were reversed between men and
women and men would marry rich older
women well I'm not going to marry a
woman that makes fraction more than I do
I think men are hypergamous in looks
yeah but what I mean is I'm talking if
there's some weird upside down bizarre
world of we're all reversal you know
it's crazy you know women are actually
harsher on looks than men are now I
believe that yeah yeah yeah I think I
think I think men the same way women
want a man who's their level and up in
terms of economic standing men want a
woman his level of attractiveness or up
in terms of that's not what I see
because I see a lot of like like fat
chicks with skinny dudes but today I was
in Bento Center and I was asking I was
just asking my sister like how did that
happen but I think this couple I think
in regards to that though like it's
different him wanting that and him being
able to get it if he had the options on
the table Yeah well that's what I'm
saying but I think matters still like
pickier or women are still pickier than
men even when it comes to looks I think
so yeah yeah yeah so even though they're
hyper pergamus it's just like the way
the dating Market is now yeah men take
what they can get yeah a lot of times
yeah because you don't have that much
option so did you show them the chart um
I couldn't find it or if you just Google
it it's not images
but the thing is I mean that was it was
a gentleman I think on this show before
he says if you're in the desert and
you're starving you're going to take
whatever food they put in front of you
yeah it doesn't matter if it's some
mashed up meat or bugs or whatever
because you're starving you're in the
desert
um yeah and so in in a sense and it's
not for some men certainly it's a sexual
desert out there and they literally are
unable to
it's fine whatever
um so question for the girls
if a guy was in the one percent or let's
let's you know let's do top five percent
so now and he wants to date you
but you have to share him
no I even say on the first date like
just be honest about the type of
relationship you want if you want
polygamy good luck to you it's not for
me if you want polyamory good luck to
you it's not for me I don't get mad at
that so would you rather have a guy that
makes less money and is monogamous to
you yeah okay
so oh let's actually I'm gonna up it one
percent this guy's multi-millionaire
you get you get the lifestyle so you get
cars nice house and it's just casual so
when he cheats it's just side chick
like like the thing is I get that yeah
good for him yeah but I wouldn't I
wouldn't you wouldn't do it no I
wouldn't do it
yeah okay
um I'd like to believe that I could but
no it wouldn't work no no
yeah
that's that musician he said maybe he's
like oh man
yeah so I I don't know I feel like his
wife knew from the job about the
situation but then obviously like
finding out how he does his dirt like
without a condom I'm like she could
bring AIDS you could bring gonorrhea or
whatever then she's like oh no but you
know she accepts I'm like I'm not here
for the stress no oh I'm like what did
you expect yeah exactly and that too
yeah so would you do it yeah would you
do it with rules that you agreed on no I
wouldn't do it I have a high disgust
factor I can't do it yeah so
question what if you never found out
does it matter
it does matter no it does yeah it does I
would I would burn the house down if I
found out you had a child with another
woman so I would burn that okay so a
question question vice versa do you are
you will you tell the person you marry
your body count I don't have one are you
a virgin yeah oh good fruit good for you
good for you two quick buckets
there's a diamond in the desert
the sensors
talk about needle in the haystack
wow I don't think I've ever had a girl
virgin on the show I know what about you
guys yeah yeah
um if you wanted to know I guess so okay
so I always ask guys the same question
does her body count matter if you never
found out
yeah yeah not for me no it doesn't it
doesn't matter if you never find out oh
no no it matters I there was a time I
used to simp and say no I'll be fine no
it matters because of the bonding thing
that you even talked it's also the
history of the person if you want to
combine your life with that person you
need to know their history no but I mean
you knowing the body count why does that
matter that's part of the history that's
part of the history crazy like 30. part
of the history I
feel like it's kind of like
buying a car not knowing the mileage or
like the MLG history so like it might
have been like fixed up and everything
but at least you need to know the
tangible evidence just for you to make a
decision based on whether you want it or
not because it could affect pair bonding
some women just like have issues with
that later on in their marriage because
they've had a high body count so for you
it's it's for your benefit to know so
over how old did you say you are 27 well
that's that's very impressive for what
number two for two have you found that
dating is it hard as a virgin yeah yeah
what what challenges do you find they
like to try and find like the limits
like what they can do okay
and then so they'll keep like pushing
they'll push it like let's try this no
let's try that yeah yeah yeah because
you know I've seen a lot of like very
very pretty virgins that are in the
church that have the same problems and
it seems like it's tough because like
those guys guys don't want to wait for a
virgin when they can have the next girl
for free have you found that or no yeah
yeah okay
go ahead and ask you a question
would you give me a guy that you read
like
Etc he's dating you he's happy to wait
with you would you be
open
for him to be having sex elsewhere until
you get married no
so you want him to be again disgust
Factor I'm not here for it I'm from
Zimbabwe I came here when I was 14. so I
grew up on like when you watch an advert
it's like an ads AIDS campaign video
something like oh you have to get your
partner tested so it's like ingrained in
me like I'm not here for that I don't
wanna like ask you can you go to the
clinic and get checked as long as I'm
not here for that let's let's say you
like him and you trust him right you
trust his word so if he says okay like
I'll always use protection I'd never put
you at risk right
but obviously understand it's amazing
that you know you've done that for
yourself but obviously the average
person like we live in very different
times right now the
one asked him to do something in this
level
like to me it's like a self-control
problem
for him
yeah
it's a heart it's a very hard sell I
think I know that's why it's difficult
because it's like saying because I think
it's like if he knows he's a like to be
with you he has to go vegan yeah but